Self-care for a heightal hernia, and how to deal with that yourself,
some things that you could do to be helpful. So what a heightal hernia is, you have your diaphragm
right here. And then your esophagus comes down and it has to go through a hole. So that hole
in Latin is called a heightus. So that hole in the diaphragm is where your esophagus comes through
and your stomach sits right below the esophagus. So this muscle, this diaphragm is a muscle,
and then that concentration of that rig of muscle around that hole is called a sphincter.
And that sphincter is supposed to be tight so it keeps your stomach down. So we call that a valve,
but it's really a sphincter that's holding the stomach down. That sphincter could get irritated
from different things. Things that you eat, anxiety could irritate it, something a blow in the
belly could irritate it, the way you lie down could irritate it. And that sphincter could loosen up
and then the stomach could go up into that hiatus, into that hole, and now that can tighten down,
and you can get a bubble in your stomach above that hiatus, above that hole, above that sphincter,
and the diaphragm, and then that can cause a lot of problems. The same nerves that
innovate that sphincter, innovate your heart, and you can get what's called a pseudo-cordinary
from a hiatal herdea, because you can get the exact same symptoms of a heart attack.
People have gone into the ER thinking that they're having a heart attack, and it's actually
a hiatal herdea issue. So to deal with a hiatal herdea, surgically, then they'll go in and pull that
down and make some stitches to snake that sphincter smaller. That's only in very, very rare conditions
that anything like that's going to need to be done. Most hiatal herdeas, probably 99% of them are
what are called functional hiatal herdeas, meaning it's not going to stay up there all the time.
Of course, that's cancer or something like that in that area. That's where it becomes more of a
clinical hiatal herdea where you have to do something with a surgical intervention.
But for a functional hiatal herdea, you want to pull the stomach down physically,
and this can take time, that muscle can take time to heal and calm down. People tend to be
prone to these. They have a weakness of that sphincter just because of irritation to their gut.
That's causing this to happen constantly. I tend to, especially when I was younger,
he was really prone to these. It was really a problem lately. It's not so much of a problem for me.
But one of the issues with this can also be that one of the causes can be actually lack of,
so what do you need to digest food in your stomach is hydrochloric acid. That's what breaks down
carbohydrates in your stomach so it can go into your swallow and test it. Would you lack
hydrochloric acid for multiple functional reasons? Look at our gut check video. We talk a little bit
about that. It can be a bacterial infection at H. Pylora in your stomach. It can be eating a bunch of
junk food so your stomach cells aren't making enough hydrochloric acid. If you're not breaking down
that food, then you could get a lot of gas formation in there that your carbohydrates are fermenting
and your stomach. That could cause this bubble to come up and that could be the cause of the
hydrochloric acid. Cleaning up a person's diet, starting to take a digestive enzyme with HCl
with your meals only, can be the solution for that. That's what fixed mind. Then you'll get that
proper digestive, you won't get that stomach pushing up that way. From a physical standpoint,
if you have the symptoms of heartburn, if you have the symptoms of acid reflux, if you have the
symptoms of stomach pain, what you want to do is tug down on the stomach. From an anatomical
position, you have your rib cage here and then you have your sternum. At the end of your sternum,
you have this little teeny bone called your zyfoid process that sticks down. You do not want to push
on your zyfoid process. That will be painful. That could be dangerous. You want to feel where your
ribs come together, where the bottom of your sternum is, and where that little teeny finger-like
bone that sticks down, just like this, called your zyfoid process is and go below that zyfoid process.
You've got to get practicing to feeling this and then you're going to go below this. This is the way I
teach doctors to do it. Once you're below the zyfoid process, your force has to be in this direction.
You're grabbing the stomach. Think of the stomach sitting there and you're going to
grabbing the stomach and you're pulling the stomach down like that. If you can envision pulling
the stomach down and you're pulling it down from the diaphragm like this, that will help you.
You go below the zyfoid process and then you're tugging the stomach down. Obviously it's harder
to do this on yourself while you can lay down on your back and do that same thing like that and
just try to pull down on your stomach. You have to relax the stomach muscles in order to do this.
If you're going to reflexively tighten up like this, then that's not going to help. Try to relax
and pull your stomach down like this. Try to relax and pull your stomach down. You're
pulling down in a direction of about 45 degrees in this way. The other thing that you have to be aware of
that can be cause of this is excessive constipation. Get your gut moving, taking some gut healing
supplements, some products that will help your gut move and get perist also going here. That will
be helpful to the other thing that can cause problems with this is anxiety. Anxiety itself can cause
that sphincter to loosen up and cause the stomach to go up. Deal with anxiety issues as well.
The other way that you can deal with this is I'll show you on myself. I work on this. When I have
stomach issues like this, I'll do it standing up tends to work better for me. I come in off my
sci-foid process and I'll just tug down like this and I'll try to stand up straight while holding my
hands there so it's just tugging down and pulling myself back while trying to hold my hands steady.
It's not a perfect procedure. It's difficult to do yourself but that could give you a lot of relief
doing that. Also if you go to a doctor that does physical medicine you might want to have them
look for adhesions that can build up along your diaphragm attachment to your rib cage and that is
where they're going to go in there and work on adhesions. You can do this yourself or have your
massage therapists or physical therapists do this as well. So some physical medicine doctor will help
with that as well because that could be an issue. Post-surgical adhesions can cause
high-endal-herty issues, digestive issues, lack of HCL in your stomach,
lack of digestive enzymes, constipation issues and anxiety. All those add those all together.
It's really easy to get functional high-endal-herty symptoms so this is one way that you can work on this.
You can't overdo it, push it on this, you can't overdo it pulling on this but you can make
yourself sore. You could even make yourself black and blue if you really pushed on it hard.
Don't do that but just constantly tongue down that that could help a lot with your symptoms.
If you're looking for a way to relax your diaphragm or your abdominal muscles when you are pushing
on that high-adal hernia is to focus on your breathing. When you breathe in you tense up and you add
air into your diaphragm and that will tighten that area up but if you focus on maybe inhaling beforehand
and exhaling as you push you tend to relax your stomach muscles and empty out your diaphragm of
air and that might help you in the process so instead of focusing on just the pushing and tightening
up to push focus on the breathing in before you push exhale as you push. There's one other thing
that is a major cause of high-adal hernia issues that we should address too and that is people that
add neck injuries so if you had a whiplash injury or even if you select wrong and you have a lot of
adhesions and inflammation in your neck remember every time you take a breath what a breath is is
your diaphragm contracting what a diaphragm contraction is is this so your diaphragm contracts like this
and by doing that it sucks it draws air into your lungs that's what a breath is so a breath is
your diaphragm polydown drawing air into your lungs so every time that happens think of your stomach
sitting right below your diaphragm like this your stomach has to drop down a little bit every time
you breathe it's going like this breath in breath out breath in breath out that means your esophagus is
moving your esophagus is moving in your chest if you get adhesions up here on your esophagus
adhesions from your clavicle these are these muscles right here go up to your neck and kind of
a triangle form here they attach to your neck there you can get adhesions in there from inflammation
in your neck from whatever reason and then that attaches to your esophagus it doesn't allow that
esophagus to slide nicely so working on having maybe a massage therapist your chiropractor
physical therapist work on some adhesions in here you could do that a little bit yourself
and you'll find that there really can be tight and sore be careful you're crotted artery
obviously be careful you don't dig in there with fingernails and hurt yourself but working on
your neck or going to somebody who can work on your neck or massage this whole area can be
extremely helpful with this too all right there's your tutorial thanks